[Musique]
bon moi c'est reto avec elle au cnes
représente 4 doigts la clique bordélique
j'ai le trac je m'appelle disloque
je viens de la courneuve des 4000
j'aimerais bien progresser donnera quoi
je m'appelle serré les jean philippe
bonjour je m'appelle l'origine je vis
dans la cité des 4000 harnois j'ai un
père qui en afrique une mère qui vient
des antilles et je suis animateur et je
fais de la musique
thomas benoit m j'habite à la courneuve
aux 4000 sud à françois villon juste à
côté de renoir j'ai 17 ans et je suis à
bonlieu bleus dans l'atelier rap on ne
vit pas de l'air du temps il faut
arrêter de rêver les gens du
gouvernement ont-ils conscience que tu
veux mais tu es une craie des lois les
applique bâle en ce jour les promesses
le résultat est le même c'est la panique
l'ampli de prix du stress laisse tomber
on compte que son temps quoi qu'est ce
qui t'arrive la nouvelle génération et
là on ne peut pas leur mentir écoute
plutôt leurs propos ils ont des choses à
dire ils sont fort relève le niveau
du rap à la courneuve dans le cadre des
ateliers d'écriture musicale du festival
de jazz en seine saint denis banlieue
bleue une vingtaine de jeunes des 4000
se sont retrouvés au coeur de leur cité
au centre culturel jean houdremont le
but de la manoeuvre produire une
émission de radio alternant rap et
interviews sur le thème l'argent et la
vie de la cité
une semaine de travail avec le
tromboniste yves robert et le rappeur
lionel des pour aboutir à une émission
diffusée la semaine dernière dans micro
sur france musique et accessoirement à
ce numéro de sagacité
[Musique]
nous dans le studio on va enregistrer
des cassettes audio du travail qui est
fait avec luigi et yves robert
on vous donnera cette cassette avec on
aider avec des donc avec les samples
dessus et vous pourrez travailler
directement sur les centres qui
travaillent en bas super voilà vous
connaissez lionel salut je m'appelle
lionel dit je viens de la ville de vitry
sur seine en région parisienne j'ai fait
un album en 1990 avec le dj dee nasty
c'est juste un indice que je te donne à
l'europe je pense que je cartonne il
faut absolument que je performe que ja
sommes enfin bref il entre le thème ça
sera ça prendra forme l'argent et la
cité ça prendra forme dans dans une dans
une formulation plus rap ou alors ils
pourraient être aussi ils pourraient
être aussi question de d'interview que
je ferai à vous sûr avec vous sur ce
sujet je ferai un à un
où peut y avoir aussi des récits on
pourra faire ça enfin des nappes des
ambiances des machins comme ça voilà bon
travail moi je travaillais au studio
avec les musiciens fait de capter le
sens tôt parce que 1,6 et 2,4 et le sens
le choix des choix
le précise pourquoi voilà tu n'auras
plus le choix mais qu'on assiste quoi
le monde a changé tant des jeunes vivent
avec le doj camouflage est obligé c'est
obligé c'est l'argent qui parvient à
braga ce domaine je sais que pour but de
vous faire la pub kralove ça o'gara bien
autour de toi on est des chalkias
riomois lève la tête soit hier se trouve
à un wiiware montre l'état d'esprit de
tous mes frères il y a des jours comme
ça où je ne sais plus quoi faire
la vie quand ce système me prouve tous
les jours tu réfléchis un bon seulement
entre n'offrait pas de bâtons dans les
roues de pandémie voilà j'ai franchement
il vous faut pas le cacher il ya la
violence tous à la délinquance mais il
ya un gars y'a un côté qui est bien
aussi il faut pas faux pas faut pas non
plus dire du mal des 4 me et ont coûté
qui est bien ce qu ici tout le monde
soutient le coup de quoi ils pas par
exemple si moi j'habite dans la cité il
n'y a pas quelqu'un qui va venir même si
la personne n'y a pas quelqu'un qui va
évidemment faire mon appartement bien
qui va manquer des deux du reste pas
moins un bon parent c'est ça qui est
bien à la courneuve c'est ça qui est
bien ou 4 ni quoi non moi la cité je les
aime bien c'est pas c'est pas parce que
j'habite là moi je suis fier d'habiter
dans ma cité je suis je suis pas content
quoi j'ai j'ai grandi là et je suis dans
quoi ya pas de problème mais c'est c'est
ce que les gens y pensent bon moment
c'est vrai que si on habite en dehors on
pense pas la même chose
j'ai vu un peu quand j'étais sur mon
cousin zone pavillonnaire ça c'est pas
les mêmes pensées ses 17 g du fait que
dans une cité il ya des histoires tout
ça mais ça c'est par tous les historiens
achète tout le monde n'est pas des mecs
qui vient de 16e et qui vient habite à
la courneuve qui va dire non la
courneuve c'est ça c'est ça on est né
avec
on restera comme on est comme un enfant
il est né avec il vas y vas mourir quand
il va mieux
les mains pour lui ce sera il est né
avec
il est né aveugle et il mourra quant à
nous c'est pareil on est née une année
aux 4000 et n'y aura pas de changement
c'est que on apprit caractère de la
banlieue les 4000 points c'est tout je
veux répéter ce qui va le répéter vont
s'asseoir et ouais ok l'état quand même
little j -christophe excuse moi et six
mois commence à dia gabart le groupe les
deux font la paire il y a
[Musique]
et mons européen entre le besoin de
vendre
rendez nous amène à faire dans la cité
il ya un an à faire part ici donc moi
comme j'ai dit je me suis mis au rap
d'axa sinon moi c'est un truc qui m'a
marqué dans la tête c'est la galère
galère c'est vrai c'est vrai que j'ai
quand j'étais petit je passe je te vas
voir quel âge pendant douze ans comme ça
il y avait un groupe de rap qui venait
de sortir qui s'appelle les sages peau
qui venait de sortir et on fait qu'on
fait comme sur froome a marqué quoi
c'est ça donne en plus à la galère c'est
chaud protège ton dos méfie-toi de
bâtons qui approche les rues la loire de
la junte eu situe pas droit tu as perdu
ça m'a marqué même si j'ai même si j'ai
presque 60 ans soixante dix ans que je
marche plus que je prends une canne pour
marcher
j'ai toujours mon souvenir du refrain
parce que ça m'a marqué ça qui m'a qui
m'a beaucoup qui m'a beaucoup donné de
l'ambition que la russie la russe est
facile à rentrer mais c'est dur à
ressortir et moi le rap c'est c'est pas
si la rentrée mais c'est essentiel c'est
pour ça que je suis bien dans le rap ça
m'arrangeait j'ai moins de problèmes
au moins je sais que j'aurai pas de
problème parce que parce qu'on commence
par une cigarette ont fini par le reste
voyez ce que je veux dire c'est pour ça
que le rap ça ça nous aide
au bout
[Musique]
michael va bien
et ben non emballées dans 20 minutes
ceux qui sont prêts comme enregistré en
bas
[Musique]
watercat partagent tous ceux qui sont
prêts comme légale en tête et ce qui
fait que leurs textes faut bien nous
concentrer parce que là on y est là au
speed est un peu normal
mélangez pas tout parce qu'il ya la
supprimer à l'autre avec ses ordinateurs
est bon le nordine n'avait par le
nordiste avait parlé avec luigi
normalement tu peux encore les scratches
va se passer sur les radios
salut salut s'allume tu m'écoutes c'est
moi qui te parle je suis là il faut lève
un peu le pied de micro il faut parler
dans le micro
alors t'es pas tout de suite dans la
musique quoi parler un petit peu les
4000 présentez-vous de ça et après vous
partez et 4,4 me demande chaque écoute
vis dior la vie dans ce système mais
prouve tous les jours que réfléchir et
mon seul recours entre nous referait
plus besoin de bâtons dans les roues de
peau de noces il ya de la méfiance quand
on en veux tu qu'on avance à minimes il
a plus de différence
plus besoin de voir les têtes reagan
d'apprentissage pour sauver de gaz
regard se base sur cette image que tout
autour de deux pages commence à notre
curité quand on est mal aimé passer de
nos moudjahidines a juste eu pour
suppléer juste pour te plaît
[Musique]
tout a changé maintenant les jeunes avec
le danger le camouflage est super g
c'est obligé d'assurer pour la musique
or c'est l'argent qui part bientôt même
tu sais ça s'appelle caf au tempo
ok mais par bien dans le tempo surtout
ça sinon ça décale les paroles à
s'allumer des crocs loin du micro hockey
junior il ya 4000 points chaque écoute
ça craint
c'est toi entendu j'ai lu qu'il faut
mettre en cage bon j'étais très timide
et j'ai bégayé comme c'est pas permis
heureusement que j'ai arrêté de bégué
parce que j'aurais pu scratch et de
devenir un sampler tu vois sampler
vivant mais vraiment j'en sortais pas
une quoi bon c'est la vie on va pas non
plus et le rap ça va complètement
débloqué parce que les premières scènes
les premiers je me rappelle de ma
première scène c'était
c'est dans la ville de créteil j'avais
appris un rap en anglais parker j'étais
mort de peur et tous les gars du
quartier qui était la plus ou moins
moqueur ironie guen il va rapper en plus
j'avais pas du tout le look s'est jamais
le look américain bon ça c'est mon
problème
et puis bon on a un petit peu encouragé
on m'a poussé et c'est comme si je comme
si j'avais plongé voit comme s'il savait
pas nager ont poussé jeune âge et ça
s'est débloqué taxe est sorti quoi je me
laissais comme une souffrance c'est un
truc qu'on ressent dans le coeur qu'on
veut qu'on veut cracher sur quelque
chose à dire nous on crache sur la
musique
si on fait ça c'est pour l'amour durable
ce qu'on aime le rap il y en a dans
notre groupe qui sont nés avec le rap
moi ça fait trois ans tu dans le ravin
moi c'est pour un monde durable comme
j'aime le dire mais pour moi le rap
c'est tout pour moi parce qu'il m'a fait
plaisir c'est leur énergie c'est entre
huy se parle c'est un langage que ça
devient presque tribal quoi ils se
parlent ils sont là moi je viens de la
cité c'est une une forme d'affirmations
quoi cesser enfin j'existe sais je suis
j'exige je suis là écoutez moi je
m'appelle un tel jeu viennent la
banlieue de la courneuve ou de
vitry-sur-seine je suis là je quelqu'un
mais coup de coin
m
[Musique]
pour ton anniversaire
qu'est ce qu'on me donne alors l'argent
que ça
c'est ce que tu demandes
voilà ce qui me fait le plus plaisir
c'est l'argent ça c'est bien ça et quand
on a de l'argent donc d'après ton
anniversaire qu'est ce tu fais avec cet
argent
j'essaie de le garder sinon je suis
assez de vêtements et j'ai vu un peu ma
mère début pourquoi
vous aidez les parents 1 pourquoi parce
que aussi nous est bon il semble que
toute façon au départ on a fait une
réunion disant bon qu'est ce que vous
voulez faire cela
j'ai envie que que de s être d'accord
pour qu'on parle d'argent pour contrat
comportant de traite de ce sujet des
noirs on préférerait parler de la cité
où est l'argent dans la cité ouais c'est
bien l'argent dans la cité est en fait
plus ça va plus on n'y a pas d'argent
dans la cité personne n'a de la rose ont
montré qu'il y avait des trucs qui se
passait quand même des jets pas quoi
quel trafic où je suis pas qu'elle je
sais pas moi et finalement ils
connaissent personne qui a vraiment de
la chance ou alors ils veulent pas le
dire peut-être devant moi j'avais pas
vraiment d'idée très préconçues donc je
vais pas très surpris parce que je
m'attendais à rien comment être surpris
de quelque chose auquel on ne s'attend
pas ce qu'on s'attend à rien
donc évidemment moi je veux leur dire
mon essence le sampa et de sang de porc
leur mission mais là c'est que du cash
cash flows rapetous pour tous un peu mon
blond et sociales sont faits à des sous
le gui sa réponse erratique il ajouté
pour abandonner pour laquelle est ce cas
serait amenée à dégrader même si on perd
demain aux données
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
nous garantit que le yoga et le mahdi
accord au maroc manon anna lou 1-2-3
lever les bras levé les bras je ne crois
pas qu'il y en a beaucoup qui juste
après la tenue vestimentaire mais
beaucoup y voient comme par exemple je
suis là ça ah ça c'est pas bon ils
disent voilà cette personne n'a fait ça
fait ça maintenant il y en a qui
limitent aux braquages et tout ça il y
en a qui disent 'voilà et puisqu'il est
sapé comme ça tout ça c'est que voilà
mais ça se dit pas c'est pas nous on est
comme tout le monde
maintenant on essaie de faire du rab
dire si on fait du rap c'est qu'on a
envie de s'exprimer c'est qu'on
s'exprime pas assez justement on a envie
de s'exprimer dans la musique dans le
domaine musical pour essayer de faire
mal pour essayer de donner une
impression tout ça pour pas que les gens
ils jusqu'à ce que j'ai envie de faire
c'est de sortir la tête haute de cette
cité si c'est de ne pas assez de ne pas
dire oui dans le plus tard dans un
bureau et que ses pensées d'aller plus
tard dans un bureau et dur chef que non
je viens pas des 4020 pas de la
courneuve
je viens d'une autre ville quoi qui
vient du 12e par exemple il veut pas
dire ça je veux dire que je viens de la
courneuve que je vendais 4006 masse est
pas c'est comme ça mais moi et jamais je
veut cacher si maxime asept que je
réussis dans son truc
voilà si c'est bien pour moi et ça ça
sera bien prenez aussi plutôt est ce que
voilà en quoi ça va faire quinze ans que
je vis dans un 4000 ne jamais rien fait
pour ils ont refait des bâtiments c'est
facile à refaire un bâtiment bon c'est
vrai que c'est coûteux tout ça mais
c'est pas ça qu'on voulait nous c'est
pas qu'on reconstruise un bâtiment pour
que ce soit la même chose d'un bâtiment
c'est facile à reconstruire parce que
c'est l'extérieur mais c'est l'intérieur
qu'il faut changer l'extérieur c'est
facile c'est ce qui se passe dedans
qu'il faut qu'il faut comprendre qu'il
faut améliorer
[Musique]
à
il faut qu'on avance la magie alors est
ce que tu entends c'est bon vas-y reflux
à l'e3 on attendait ces nouveaux
appareils micro à thouaré k-way la
débandade lève le nez bleu ouais ouais
mais tu vois ta joie
et ouais 1 2 1 2 tout le matos ipa en
cours ou sanaa
elle veut cacher leurs demandes et on va
parler mais ressent vous la belle seul
rêve ici c'est trouver du trou du du
boulot c'est tout ça va c'est le rêve de
chacun trouvera une bonne place et pays
restait un pétard savez comme tôt
[Musique]
c'est pas évident la cour trouver une
place
surtout quand vous habitez la courneuve
et une place folle a trouvé par rapport
à quelqu'un c'est pas en envoyant un cv
ça marchera jamais même si vous êtes
bien qualifiés ils ont préféré prendre
quelqu'un 2
tu que les gens son assistant a été fou
j'ai pas si vous êtes ou quand il ya
quatre villes du front national
maintenant le camouflage est obligé
c'est obligé bien sûr que pour l'ami pas
c'est l'argent qui parle quatre dom et
sucé ça c'est l'argent qui part au cours
de trois et bien des jours comme ça où
je ne sais pourquoi la vie dans ce
système de tous les jours tu réfléchis
[Musique]